we've known for a while now that player
unknowns battlegrounds will be getting a
new desert map and we got a few preview
screenshots not too long ago but now
we've finally gotten a look at the whole
thing I'm Tony and this is your
free-for-all game spot news update the
new map is called Miramar and developer
Blue Hole released a full shot of the
region complete with city names and
descriptions some highlights include
loss Lyonnaise the largest city in the
area with a ton of verticality and large
buildings the coastal town of Valdemar
chuma Serra a town of abandoned
factories and houses and the compound of
Montana AVO for a description of all the
major cities
check out game spots full write-up pub G
itself leaves early access and comes to
Xbox one via the preview program on
Tuesday December 12th you can also
expect to see the map in action at the
game Awards this Thursday the 7th and
speaking of awards
GameSpot's own game of the year coverage
has kicked off so stay tuned for our top
picks in the coming weeks
[Music]
Oh
[Music]